Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Vitess, a graduated
cloud native foundation project
that helps to aim,
that
aims to help with clustering and scaling MySQL.
To join me today,
I have Adepti and Alkin. They are maintainers
from the Vitess project and
employees of PlanetScale Data.
Hi there. How are you both?
Hello. Yeah.
Alright. I think what we should do is
start with introductions. I'd love to get to
know you both a little bit. So who
would like to go first?
I'll let Diti go first, please. Okay.
Yeah. Please tell us a little bit about
yourself, and then then we'll move on.
My name is Vitessigreedi.
I'm a software engineer at PlanetScale,
and I have
been with the company for
over two years, getting close to three years
now. PlanetScale
itself was founded in early two thousand eighteen,
so it's just about three years old.
I started working on Vitess at PlanetScale in
late twenty eighteen, and I became a maintainer
in 2019.
We have a maintainer team with 16 members,
and, I've been a maintainer since. And in
my maintainer role, I
communicate with the community,
answer questions on Slack, attend conferences,
mostly cube cons, but also other conferences where
I give talks about Vitess.
I am currently the tech lead, so I
also
manage the road map for Vitess and
just I'm involved in high level technical and
architectural decisions
on the project.
Alkan?
Alright.
Thanks,
Okay. My name is Alkan,
and I come from an enterprise world. And
I'm an open source database evangelist for the
for the last almost ten years, a decade
or so. And, I've been working in in
the MySQL specific projects in areas for, like,
services companies.
And I have joined PlanetScale
about six months ago and, been engaged in,
conferences and and
webinars before.
So,
what I am doing at PlanetScale is part
of the maintainer team, developer relations,
and,
also a little bit of, multiple hats over
here with customer success and solution engineering
and and so on. So
I love sailing,
so some people know.
And
that's about it.
Nice. Well, it sounds like you both keep
yourself extremely busy.
Yeah. Awesome.
Well,
why don't we kind of just take a
a few moments? I know we've got some
slides that's gonna explain
what Vitess is, why people need to, etcetera.
So,
why don't you get your screen shared up?
We'll move that over. Let me share my
screen real quick.
Alright. Chrome tab.
Hope you can see it.
Yep. It is just coming. There we go.
Perfect. Alright. So okay. We're done with the,
inter introduction. So PlanetScale, we talked about that
was founded in February. The the significance of
of PlanetScale is the co creators of Vitess
are actually
the the founders of of PlanetScale. So there
is a mutual
relation between the Vitess project and the
and the founders. So,
basically,
our creators are the co owners,
technically speaking. So a clustering system,
we don't call it a clustering system, technically.
It's actually a framework because it comes in
bells and whistles. CNCF
graduated project, if you have ever looked into
CNCF, there are multiple projects. This is one
of the earliest database projects. There are many
projects that the the list is is long
and very successful applications over there.
And,
it's open source, Apache two point zero license.
That's important.
And we have contributors around the community around
the world also, so it's not actually US
centric at all. The we also decided to
highlight this. It's written in Go link, and
and contributors
should be aware of it's it's a Go
language that's used.
And Go comes with a lot of
updates to existing
breed of languages,
so we are actually
Go shop.
So
so today, we wanna talk about the agenda
on on the architecture,
use cases, and how do we actually install,
possibly show a demo with you.
So let's let's get into the architecture basics.
We have
let's go actually talk about the glossary. So
we have some terms,
which is database terms but adopted to Vitess.
Vitess is not a database. I need to
highlight that. Vitess is a framework, drives the
database. So the MySQL in the back end
MySQL is still good old,
well, not good, but MySQL is great. So,
it's a it's a great database in the
back end. So we don't actually make any
changes to the database. Database still remains to
be,
in one piece, but we actually drive the
database with Vitess,
edition. So we call, a key space a
database, which is which one when it's sharded.
So it actually had to be something other
than a database.
So when it's sharded, it has a key
space ID. It has a primary v index
and a v index that actually knows where
the shards are. There's a v t gate.
The proxy server accepts the connections, and the
v t tablet is the back end server
which pairs with the MySQL database.
And there's a topology that knows what's what's
what's going on within the
cluster.
So,
let's talk about a a common replicated environment.
So we have a a database,
a sidecar that actually runs the the MySQL
daemon
process,
and we call this a VT tablet. So
each VT tablet is paired with with
same host as the as the MySQL d
runs.
And you will have multiple VT tablets.
And so
it's it's a it's a VT tablet
which which paired with
it has a responsibility of of running the
database,
but also driven by the VTgate. So VTgate
is actually our our proxy
where the application connects to. So when you
actually make a connection to the to the
Vitess cluster,
you actually go through the Vitess gate. Vitess
Vitess
is the is the query serving
property of of Vitess,
and and that actually points to the Vitess.
So in a in a large deployment, you
would have multiple VT gates. You don't actually
have one.
Technically speaking, one VT gate cannot or be
possibly be responsible for all the queries. We're
talking about hundreds of shards in in in
some cases,
thousands of servers in in behind or or
or nodes.
VTgate would also have to scale, and that's
that's this is how you would actually scale.
And,
and then well, your application,
connects to the VTgate.
And then at that point, you need to
know
where is my data. So in this example,
we have a commerce database which is sharded,
and, it has two shards.
And,
how do we know
where that query needs to point to? Vitessgate
knows where your, actually,
data sits.
So if you are actually sharded by the
customer ID
and then your in n number of customers
sits on one shard, and then VTgate would
know when you send a query to that
shard. And you can also have an uncharted
cluster within Vitess. This is also something we
need to clarify.
You do not have to shard
when you're using Vitess. Vitess also support supports
uncharted
just like the good old, you know, database
applications,
but you would also have the benefits of
the
the proxy server, the topology server,
and additional
products that actually bundled in the Vitess framework.
So we actually
query your customer ID to that shard. And
in this example,
we can
know where the shards are. So the next
thing is is the is the VT gate
that actually
works with the topology server. So in this
example, we have
supported topology
servers that knows your cluster. So you need
to actually store
all this information
into where where they sit and and keep
them up to date.
The this allows the the Vitess framework to
know the state of the of the the
cluster
at all times. So it actually keep updating
if things change or if things move.
And in this example, we also say it's
CD or Zookeeper are are are
supported
topology managers.
So we are
a VTCTLD
is a a control daemon. That's another component
of the Vitess,
and that runs the the ad hoc operations
and bunch of other things. So since
the it's a control plane, you need to
actually have a have a way to change
things around and and and apply changes.
So VTCTLD
actually is the daemon that actually
controls all that.
So
we we said the keeping the state,
Vitess knows the schemas, shards, clusters, several roles,
and all that all that stuff as as
a state in the TOPL.
So the the when we look at the
the control plane,
we have we talked about the VT gates,
the proxy server.
We also have a built in backup and
recovery,
and and it pretty much automated. When when
a when a node fails, it takes a
backup and then restores it and then connects
the dots, and then replication resumes where it
left off.
We have integrated failover, which is an a
very popular known
open source
utility called Orchestrator as a VTORC within the
cluster.
The sharding schemes are are are are optional.
You can actually customize how do you want
to shard. You don't actually have to shard
by customer ID in that example.
There are other ways to do that. Advanced
replication options with the vreplication and vstream, these
are, like, components of Vitess that you actually
control how you want to replicate from and
to.
This is
one step beyond the
built in replication that that MySQL provides.
Of course, there's an online DDL option that
when you have to actually do a schema
migration or schema changes or, you know, in
short, alter table,
you would actually still drive
GitHub online schema transfer or or Percona Percona
Toolkit online schema change
utility.
And this is also driven by Vitess itself
or do a direct up supply.
In summary, the Vitess architecture looks like this.
We have the application server that actually connects
the to your your preferred load balancer, which
actually points to VT gate. You're gonna say,
okay. I have a proxy. Why do I
need load balancer? Because you might have multiple
VT gates and and scale out. So that's
that's why. And then you have BTCTLD
daemon that control the
the architecture,
and the topos server knows where where things
are. And then you have the the tablets
and the clusters that's driven by by by
tablet with the your your primary, your replicas,
your your read only replicas, and then you
can actually scale out based on your application.
This is not like this is an example.
This is not just one standard application. You
actually may actually have to customize it based
on your workload, we call it.
Supported back end databases are MySQL 5.7
and version eight, and and we we also
have MariaDB support. It does not work on
PostgresQL,
and Postgres is not in the road map
at this time, or there is not much
of a development that actually. So we can
call Vitess is is pretty much MySQL centric
framework
at this point.
You can you can like in that example,
you can
have a a sharding done on the entire
application or part of that application. So there
is a mix and match from the community
that we know uses not entire. Like, we
cannot say, okay. This entire
shop is on Vitess, but, you know, where
it needed to scale
or or fit for Vitess is is migrated
in that. And then the Vitess
allows sharding and resharding. So when you shard
in the in the old school, it's it's
you're pretty much stuck.
But with Vitess, if you shard, you can
reshard. You can change your your your your
methods.
And then within the video application and the
tools provided, you can migrate it into new
new
method.
And so this the idea is to minimize
backup and recovery. Hopefully, I'm not out of
time,
and and we have more resources at these
things. And we'll share we'll share these slides
also.
Perfect.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright. There was
many more components there than I was expecting.
So I just wanted to make sure I
can I understood enough of that where we're
going? Like,
it says that so
Vitess augments
MySQL and MariaDB. Right? It's it's not replacing
them. We're still using those standard databases and
our infrastructure that that has not changed. So
but what it does do is provide a
proxy that's gonna handle all the requests that
we wish to send our database and that
provides a
some sort of hashing key mechanism to shard
that across multiple MySQL, MariaDB's and I don't
even need to worry about it. I think
that alone is particularly cool.
But then you kept coming with all this
other stuff, like online backups and the restore
processes.
Just
all these little things that are really cumbersome
when it comes to working
with my scale specifically. I think we've all
worked with it at some point over the
years. Like, trying to scale it beyond a
certain point is always very, very challenging.
I wish Vitess had existed in 02/2010
just from what you've showed me there in
those slides. So I'm really excited to play
with it today and and see some of
this in action.
So,
like, I'm
curious about
third party tooling.
So I'll just throw a few questions out
now before we go into the hands on
bit. But does if I wanna use, like,
a a MySQL browser on my local machine
and it goes through
the test, would that cause any sort of
problems, or would that just work?
It depends on the tool that you're using.
I'm trying to remember what it is that
we tested with.
There there are popular MySQL inspection
tools with
GUIs
that we have been able to get working
with Vitess.
Yeah.
So I'm assuming that the Vitess proxy just
speaks the protocol and it kind of intercepts,
tries to understand the query. I mean, does
it even do a query plan into point
if I do a select across multiple shards
so that it knows to direct them to
the appropriate ones? Is that something that's part
of the
Right. So that's all part of the proxy.
It does speak to MySQL protocol and parses
the query and uses the past query to
figure out how to route it.
And for certain complex queries, you actually have
to do a scatter gather, send it to
multiple
shards
and process the results. For instance, if you're,
doing some aggregate function in the query that
or an order by, then that might require
additional processing in memory in the proxy layer
to send back the proper results to the
client.
Okay. That's that's
that's pretty cool. Like, I'm a so even
if I'm only running against one MySQL, I'm
still seeing value in using something like Vitess
even early on in my project. Like, just
bringing it in, having it there, working quite
happily, I still get all of that extra
functionality even if I don't particularly need to
drop into the sharding stuff quite yet. Okay.
Then I think we should just play with
it and then see how easy it is
to get working. So let's jump over to
my screen share. I have here the Vitess
documentation,
which we'll use as our kind of guides
today.
I have Docker for Mac running
with nothing, I hope.
Yeah.
Nothing running at the moment. So
I see that there's a Kubernetes quick start.
There's the local install.
Is that fair to say that there's nothing
that
binds me to Kubernetes to use the test?
I could use that in more traditional bare
metal like environments just the same without Kubernetes,
or is Kubernetes
is some of the functionality limited to the
Kubernetes
runtime?
Kubernetes is not required.
There are large installs that are running outside
of Kubernetes
and large installs that are running within Kubernetes.
Mhmm.
What you
do get with Kubernetes is
sort of
being able to use Kubernetes primitives to manage
your cluster versus writing your own tooling. Everyone
who
is doing it on their own kind of
had to write some tooling to schedule backups
and things like that.
Whereas in Kubernetes, you can
do that much more easily,
especially because there is, an operator for Vitess,
which is also open source.
Wow. So my take on on the Kubernetes,
thank you, for for that insight.
My take on on the Kubernetes, Kubernetes is
cloud native. So when you do that in
Kubernetes, you're already in the cloud,
which comes with also a lot of tools
and utilities, including load balancer,
storage, your, you know, your uploads, your, you
know, your gateway, your security, your keys,
all of that is you're already in like,
let's say you're using Google and GKE and
and launch a cluster
in
Kubernetes,
you already get everything at your, you know,
customization.
You can actually set things up
and and utilize those. If you're on local,
then you need to figure out, okay. What's
my storage? How do I, you know, get
a load balancer?
Where where do I run, you know, another
node? Let's say, you need to run an
application. Are you gonna run it on Kubernetes,
or are you gonna actually,
launch a, you know, virtual machine?
But you still need a cloud. In that
case, if you're in the in the Kubernetes,
you get all that. The other thing is,
like like, Diti said, the
operator if you have an operator,
which means
many things are are are
automated.
So
within the operator, there's a logic that runs.
Okay. If this node dies,
bring another node,
attach it to your your source or or
primary,
and then connect
and then
continue as nothing happens because the nodes can
die in Kubernetes. Right? That's normal. But in
in your local, if a node dies, then
you need to figure out, okay. What what
happened to that? Right? And then there is
not much of an automation in as in
that in that sense.
So that's that's the those are the difference.
And the pros and cons of the learning
curve versus the old school and how you
how you did things in the past. Right?
Excellent. Thank you. Yeah. You're right.
I'm a big fan of operators in general.
I think they are taking,
you know, all that experience from people like
yourselves that are running these things or have
done in the past and trying to encapsulate
that into a binary that I run on
my Kubernetes cluster to make my life easier.
I am all for that. I will take
all the operators that exist out there.
Glad to hear this is Vitess one.
So I guess we're just gonna click on
the Kubernetes quick start for today and get
this deployed to my local cluster.
Yeah.
I can probably are we gone do you
want to go with the operator or are
we just gonna go with the the manifest?
Is there a preference there?
We
we should do the the operator. Yes. Mhmm.
Okay. So I'll just clone down this directory.
So this is actually the main the test
directory. Is this just the mono repo then?
This
is the the Vitess mono repo. And
within this, we have an example on how
to run it with the operator. The operator
lives in its own repo. Alright. Okay. Gotcha.
And I noticed there that also oh, what
did I get wrong?
Oh, I'm not in the right directory.
Example.
Alright. Okay. It's always my problem when things
go wrong. It's always me failing to type
basic things.
Yeah. I noticed here that this is the
Helm chart is deprecated. Is that in favor
of another chart or just something that, you
know,
the Vitess community has decided that Helm isn't
the right way to work with it?
The helm chart predates the operator, and it
was useful before an operator was available. Once
PlanetScale started working on this operator that they
intended to open source,
the community
decided that they didn't want to support the
Helm chart anymore.
So,
at that point, we deprecated it.
Yeah. I think Helm is great for for
starting things up, but operators are much better
for ongoing
management
of Kubernetes clusters.
Yeah. I I think if you don't have
to maintain a health chart, that's a fantastic
thing. I maintain some popular charts, and they've
actually become a burden now.
Trying to,
like, satisfy every use case in the world
from every user of that help chart is
no easy feat.
Okay. So I am going to deploy
what was it called? Operator.YAML?
Yep. There we go.
So the operator is on Docker Hub, so
it's it's
getting downloaded from Docker.
Yeah. I noticed you didn't need to install
any operator source.
Yeah. And it looks like it's just installed
some custom resource definitions. We've got some service
accounts and probably roll bindings.
Oh, I do see actually
a priority class for scheduling. That's that's interesting.
I don't often see that when I install
operators.
Is that just to ensure that if a
test operator isn't infected?
I guess I guess it becomes quite an
important part of my, you know, if I'm
running the stateful workloads on Kubernetes, like I
probably don't want to have a test operator
to disappear. I think Oh, got it. I
understand why that's there. Okay.
Let's move on. So we wanna bring up
our initial cluster. I'm just gonna pop this
one open and we'll take a look at
what's actually going on here.
Okay. So we are
requesting
a Vitess cluster
and then we have the ability to overwrite
any of the images.
Is that something that a regular end user
would have to do or is that really
just there as a convenient function for the
developers of the project?
So
what we do with these versions is that
on release branches, when we do a Vitess
release, we do a compatible
example.
So that tag will
be a release tag versus being latest.
And if people are, choosing a specific Vitess
release to go live with, then they will
pin these versions to those releases.
Yeah. Okay.
And I see some vocabulary that I'm not
familiar with in this context. So could we
maybe break down what a a cell is
here?
Right.
So in Vitess terminology,
cell is any failure domain. So it can
be a group of servers, a data center,
an availability zone, a region.
Typically, it's an availability zone when you're deploying
in the cloud. So here, we are basically
saying
we've got one cell, and we call it
zone one because
it represents an a z.
Right. Okay. Gotcha.
And then we have how many replicas we
want. We have some rules resource constraints and
then the authentication model. So should I apply
this now before we go through it? Will
this take a little bit of time to
get up and running, running or is it
pretty quick?
It should be pretty quick. Are you on
me, Cube right now? It's just talker for
Mac.
Okay. Yeah. It's it's pretty
yeah. It should it should go fast. We'll
let it go. I'm sure.
Okay.
So then we have something called a Vitess
dashboard,
which seems to reference the cells that we
specified.
We've got some extra flags, replicas. So do
we when we use the Vitess operator to
deploy our
MySQL clusters with the proxies and stuff also
get, like, a UI that we can navigate
and explore?
Yes. This UI gives you a view of
the Vitess cluster. It it will you can
also see the schema, but you don't actually
have the ability to navigate down to, like,
a table level with this UI. And it's
very primitive, very old, and we have a
couple of volunteers who are replacing that,
and hopefully, that'll be available in the near
future.
Alright. Okay.
Alright. Now we have something Coming soon. VT
admin.
Something called a keys
keyspace.
That seems to tie into the slides that
you kinda presented at the start there, Alkin.
Do you wanna just quickly run us through
what we're defining here? The key space is
is the database, basically. So we have launching
commerce
database
with, you know, initial
DB dot SQL that it runs the tables.
So it's gonna create three three tables in
this example,
and it's gonna build a database within that
zone one cluster. And then it will build
one primary to,
I believe, two replicas around it.
Or it's one yeah. It's two replicas. Yes.
Okay. How much
you know,
if I'm coming at this with a a
new project, like, completely greenfield, I haven't got
anything yet. I I wanna go with MariaDB,
and I think, well, I'll start off early.
I'm gonna bring in Vitess to help prepare
for that eventual skill. Like how set in
stone is this configuration of shards and partitions?
Like is this something that's that I can
tweak as I grow as a company, or
do I really have to have an idea
early on of how to set this up?
Did you wanna answer that? Or Yeah. Sure.
So it's not set in stone at all.
You can start with uncharted,
and then you can
update your configuration
and roll out the changes.
And the operator can provision the new
pods for you.
And
there are commands that you can issue to
copy over the data from
let's say you started uncharted. You have one
shard and you decide my data has grown
large enough. I have a couple of terabytes.
I wanna break it up into two shards.
Yep. Then,
all the commands are available for you to
initiate a copy from the unsharded
space to the sharded space. And
once the copy is complete,
to be able to cut over to switch
over the traffic from the old to the
new.
And that's a core part of Vitess. That's,
most of the large Vitess installs
would not be able to work without that
ability.
So I
just wanna make sure I understood this correctly.
So I've got my application. I'm running an
uncharted. The data is it's getting too big.
It's too crazy. I know I wanna
horizontally scale less than some fashion.
Does my system go offline during this migration?
Can I no longer accept rates or does
it do everything
like
actively while that's happening in the background? What
what what's the burden on me as an
operator at that point?
All of the actual data migration happens in
the background.
And even the v t gate endpoint that
your application is connecting to won't change.
But when you initiate the cutover, we'll have
to stop accepting rights
for a few seconds Mhmm. So that we
can cut over to the to the new
primary
and then start accepting rights again. So there
may be a few seconds when any rights
sent by the application to the Vitess cluster
may block
and then start getting through again.
Okay. You know what? So in this example
that you're actually running,
initial cluster example, is something
similar that it mimics. So there's there's a
story behind this. Right? So there is there
is a the story is you have an
ecommerce
application that decide started growing. So you already
have
accepting reads and writes to that cluster.
Okay? So this is what you're building. Once
you build this, you have the the old
version. And then we what we do is
we we keep adding on and then migrate
that data
within
the Vitess
realm.
But if
you had already had a MySQL that's running
and then you decided to go with TestFace,
so first, you need to come to Vitess
uncharted
way within the Vitess. So you come from
outside
and migrate into that. And there's there's a
way to do that. Also, migrate that, like,
with a replication. You set up a replication,
and you cut over, and then you fail
over to that Vitess after that. So that
once you're in Vitess, then you do one
more migration to the uncharted to a charted.
That's the story.
Okay. I mean, I So in fact Sorry,
Andrew. Go ahead.
In fact, in this very example, we'll go
through that resharding process.
Oh, nice. Okay. So we'll be able to
see that.
Well, I mean, if it's only a few
seconds, I'm a very happy person. So let
let me just like,
I think all the things we're talking about
just they sound
like great. I can't imagine ever being a
situation where I've got MySQL and MariaDB backing
my application where I would say I don't
want this. Is it fair to say that
anybody who's MySQL and MariaDB should just use
Vitess by default? Is that the mission?
That is the mission.
Alright. That that is the ultimate goal.
There we go. Perfect.
Alright. So that was just some secret stuff.
We could see we're doing a little bit
of import
of data. So in theory,
we've given that a little bit of time
now.
I can run, get the test cluster.
We have our example cluster. I always like
to run a describe and see what I
get back to. So let's do that.
And
I'm not sure if those are old or
new messages,
but we got some potentially error stuff there.
And let's see if we have any pods.
Okay. Yeah. So those were just, I guess
as it spends up a new Vitess cluster,
it's likely that a few things are gonna
fail until it becomes healthy.
Right.
But we do have
we have an ETCD.
We have the V tablets.
We have a
test control D and then the VT gate.
So
this is
my new cluster. Right? These are all the
components. We kind of got a rough idea
of what those all now.
Mhmm. That was quite easy. That was it.
Yep. So it's it's CD itself is redundant
over there. You can see. And the tablets
are are
also redundant, and you have the other components.
Those are those are stateless, so they're
basically
single,
and the operator is its own driver.
Why does Vitess use HCT?
HCD is not the only option. You can
also use Zookeeper,
but I'm guessing your question is more of
why do you even need a distributed data
store. Right?
Yeah. Why don't MySQL and MariaDB? Like
So
we we would like to, get to using,
Vitess cluster itself as the data store for,
the discovery.
Yeah.
Okay. It historically,
when Vitess was being built at YouTube,
they already had a, quote, unquote, log server
available from Google.
So it was easy for them to say,
we don't have to worry about building this
part ourselves. We'll just use what is available.
But it does definitely make sense to
store the same data in a MySQL or
MariaDB.
Yeah. I think that would be quite a
cool story, you know, bootstrapping for test with
Vitess. Like, wait. Like
anyway My answer would be my answer would
be
nontechnical.
So it's it's more
the community adopted
and best practice kind of thing. People know
about it. It works, and it it has
no, like, hiccups.
And I
think this is what drives people to, okay,
NCD,
fine. It works, and let's keep it. You
know? Like, this
this is more like a nontechnical
in the sense. But there's like, the Helm
charts and and maybe console,
there are some technical difficulties
the community adopters had, so they actually didn't
actually pursue
using them.
Okay.
Well,
yeah, that's this is all really useful.
I guess
I was about to deviate from the documentation.
I'm trying to get better at not doing
that.
So
let's let's stick with it. I was just
gonna deploy WordPress to go, let's connect the
dots, but I'll I'll behave myself. So
we can get pods which we've done. We've
verified everything is running, everything is happy. The
documentation even shows here that, you know, you
will see a couple of restarts. I think
that's really good.
And then what can we do? So
there's a client I can use. Is that
what this is telling me now?
Yeah. In that in that step is one
of the things, is to setting up port
forward. So since you're in the operator and
the Kubernetes, you need to port forward,
how you wanna access the the Vitess
client
and the MySQL,
which which actually is behind the VT gate.
Right? So you
would set up a port forward with that
script
and set aliases for the
VTCTL
client and the MySQL on your on your
shell.
Yeah. So it it wants me to do
that because it wants to create this kind
of schema. So
how about we deviate then and we deploy?
Like, we don't actually need to deploy the
do we? We could we just deploy WordPress
and point it to it and walk through
that, or is there something unique about the
schema stuff that we should go over?
We don't need to deploy the schema, but
we do need to do the port forward
because that
host port is what you will then give
to WordPress.
Unless you're deploying WordPress in cluster, in which
case, you don't need to do the port
forward. Yes. I will deploy it in cluster.
Okay.
Yeah. Then then you can just connect to
Vitigate
with the partner. I'm assuming we have a
service
address. Right? Yeah. We do. So
would I connect WordPress to the v tablet
or the v gate? I'm sorry. To to
the to the v gate. V gate. V
Okay.
So I do have a
well, I did have something in my buffer.
Let me grab that again.
On the official Kubernetes
examples, reposits where they do ship a WordPress
deployment. So let's just
download that. I need a workload folder,
and we should be able to see this
here.
Let's try again.
That's better. So we have our workload folder
here and we have a WordPress
YAML fail.
I don't think I need to
Oh yeah, we'll need to set the host
and stuff like that. So
if we're going with the Kubernetes service address,
then we want
That's interesting
with the service. So I can see that
we're actually getting like a generate name happening
here.
Why is it not just example VT gate?
Is it I guess, I'm potentially gonna have
more than one VT gate at some point?
Okay. Yeah.
So one thing I'm not sure about here,
and maybe I'll can notice, is there's an
example, we t gate, and there's an example
zone one, t gate. There are two of
them.
I'll can does it matter which one we
use?
Let's just try one and see how it
goes. Yeah. I I don't think it matters.
Yeah. You can just use
Okay.
Okay. So I'm gonna drop this in.
That's gonna be the default effect. We we
work with that one too. Okay.
And we can figure it off through
the secret,
which was an error initial cluster.
Can I just grab the username and password
from Yeah? Okay. So it's just user with
no password. Is that right?
Is that what that means?
Yeah. That's what that means. I'm just wondering
if it if an empty string is, like,
the operator are gonna in some way randomly
generate a password for me, but we'll try.
No. No.
Oh, no. That's actually the one to see.
Oh, no.
I know better than you, Kubernetes. There we
go. Password blank.
And
we'll just set
this to
now we have to play the game as
a DB user or DB username, so we'll
find out. And
then the rest of that should just work
as is. I don't think there's anything.
Yeah. Let's see.
So in theory, I can now do a
deploy of WordPress.
We'll see if that comes up happy.
Hopefully it builds that image pretty quick.
This is normally where I would say control
C and describe it and then it would
say it's healthy and I was just being
impatient,
but
now I'm gonna describe it.
One part has unbounded media. Okay.
Why
does that need persistent storage? Storage?
And why does it not work?
Storage classes.
Okay. We've only got a host pass from
Docker for Mac.
Today, I learned.
So
let's do
host pass.
I'm not even sure if I can just
make this up, we're gonna find out. If
that doesn't work, I'll remove the PVC and
we'll just stick it with ephemeral. I don't
really think it's gonna matter for what we're
doing today.
So we'll see what happens.
There, it's happy. Okay.
So I should now be able to port
forward
to WordPress.
And it should have enough information that the
wizard we're gonna get probably gonna fill itself
in.
I'm saying hopefully.
Connection refused.
I spoke to soon.
Okay. So it's failing to write
the database now. And our VT gate. So
it looks like it did reach our VT
gate, but the VT gate is saying that
creating a database is not allowed.
Right.
So what port are you connecting to VT
gate?
No. No. No. That's not the issue. So
I did not realize that WordPress does issues
a create database. In Vitess, a database is
a key space, which is backed by all
of the infrastructure.
So if you do create database, then
what
you are expecting is that you bring up
all of these processes.
So I think we have to do the
create database manually and then connect it up.
Well, we did actually. Right? We we did
generate a key space. So if I've understood
this correctly,
the database name is commerce?
Yes. Okay. So we can I am going
to assume very naively that I can just
do name WordPress
DB
name
value commerce?
Assuming I know how to spell commerce.
Yeah. Good. Okay.
And we don't need that.
Yeah.
Now it's not gonna have any problem.
Will creating the tables with the schema cause
any problems or should that just work out?
No. Create table should work. Okay. So let's
try reapplying our workload,
and we should see a restart. Yep.
We'll just keep an eye on that for
a moment.
And if I guess it's past the create
database, then the port forward should hopefully give
me that nice kind of wizard screen.
There's a lot of hopefullys on this stream.
Well,
that's better.
There. Okay.
So Vitess,
Rawkode.
I wonder if it's gonna let me away
with that. Yeah. There we go.
And
my email address. Definitely don't index as Google.
Okay.
So
that seems Nice. So trivial. But
at the same time, I wanna just emphasize
something here. Emphasize something here. Like,
WordPress does not know it's speaking to Vitess.
It thinks it's just speaking to MariaDB or
MySQL.
And I never had to change anything.
Is is that standard then when I adopt
Vitess? Like, you know, if my application speaks
MySQL and MariaDB,
I should just expect it to work with
very little changes. Is is that correct?
It depends on how assortative
MySQL features are that you are using.
So certain things,
like, say, show binary logs will not make
sense to send to a proxy.
And some
complex cross shard queries still don't work.
Sometimes because
they are
harder to plan, and we haven't done it
yet. And sometimes because they would be so
inefficient that maybe we should not support them.
Maybe
the application should be rewritten in a more
efficient way.
Okay. But most things most things should work.
Anything that doesn't work is
somewhat obscure.
And if there is a common thing that
doesn't work, then we are fixing it.
Or it's not it's a new feature.
Like, there's
there's a like, my c like like I
mentioned, MySQL
itself excels in every version, every release. Right?
So they keep adding
enhancements and new features.
And those are not always caught up with
the framework.
Yeah. We are definitely not caught up with
MySQL eight dot o. There are features there
that we that Vitess doesn't understand right now.
Yeah. I I
mean, I'm that's just running my SQL right
now. It's like, I wanted to run MariaDB,
would that have just being a flag in
my my cluster dot YAML.
Yes. We will need a different build.
Right. Okay. A different image.
Yeah. I mean, my personal preference is MariaDB,
but that's just mine. I try to avoid
anything that's got Oracle branded and stamped on
it. But other than that, that's people are
welcome to use what they want. Okay.
That is really cool. I'm I'm really happy
with that. So
I think we're kind of covered on what's
this,
not what's the same, but you know, we've
hooked up an application that doesn't require any
changes to work other than that little caveat
about,
you know, you have to create your key
spaces as part of the operator and the
cluster definition. I think that makes perfect sense.
Should we dive into the
What's different under the hood? Can we take
a look at the tools and the schemas
and how we interact with this cluster?
Is there is there documentation for that? And
I'm just making things up. Is there something
you wanna point me to here?
So do you have in mind?
Like, what would you like to see?
So yeah. I'm just curious. Like, how do
I, you know, take a look at you
said there was a UI. Should we take
a look at that first?
Yeah. We can do that. Okay.
So I gotta run get pods. This is
where everything is. I mean, I don't see
something there that says UI. Is that something
we have to deploy separately, is it just
a port on one of these other components?
It's support on that VTCTLD
component.
This one, okay.
So if I describe this,
Clarence is well described first.
Let's take a look at the ports.
So 15,000
or fifteen nine nine nine?
Fifteen thousand is the HTTP port. Okay. Fifteen
nine nine nine is the gRPC port.
Is all communication in Vitess over gRPC?
Pretty much. Yeah.
There are there is a JDBC driver which
you can use to talk to
the Vitess cluster. So from outside, we can
speak gRPC,
MySQL protocol, and Java.
But,
within Vitess, it's all gRPC as of now.
I did that. One less zero. Yeah.
Okay. So Let's go to app two. Let's
go to app two.
Just like a new and improved slash app.
Seems to keep redirecting me. Okay. That's fine
then.
Yeah. So this is the,
sort of cluster view.
You can see that there is a key
space called commerce, and it has one shard,
and you can click through to that.
Click into that.
There's
a master which we will shortly rename to
primary
and a replica.
So status
oh, I can't click it. Looks like it's
clickable. Yeah.
That that that link doesn't work within Kubernetes.
Alright.
Okay.
So I can run health checks.
I can delete the tablet. That sounds scary.
I hope there's a confirmation on that. And
I'm kinda There is there is confirmation.
Okay.
Alright.
So if I We can look at
Sorry. Please go ahead. Sorry. I was gonna
say we can look at the schema. So
schema is viewable from this
Though it says there is no schema.
That's interesting.
That is interesting.
Yeah. I'm pretty sure we have a schema.
I'm I'm assuming WordPress has deployed something
into this. Right. Right.
Is there a command line tool? Probably,
there is a command line tool that you
can use to do get schema. But my
guess is that
because the schema was applied
by WordPress,
it did not make it into the topology
server.
Whereas if you use the Vitess command apply
schema, it stores it in the topology and
propagates it to the MySQL.
Okay. That would be my guess.
So this is our topology manager here.
Mhmm.
I'm just gonna keep clicking on stuff.
Which is what I did the first time
I saw this.
Yeah. So we can kinda see some stuff
about the partitions and the replicas and all
that. Okay. Right.
Yeah. So you said there was an app
v two or at least an app two.
Is that something that's currently being worked on
by the team? Is that just an improvement
on what we see here? Like, what what
what was the app two?
Well, app two is this, but there is
a new
UI that is being
worked on, which will probably have its own
starting page.
Okay.
Alright. Let's look at a couple more things
then, and we'll we'll leave the UI alone
for now. I think I've clicked everything there
is there now. So
I'm curious,
now that I have
my Vitess cluster here,
if I want to change the properties of
this,
I'm assuming I just work like with my
standard Kubernetes tooling and just
change the spec.
Right.
Now
where was So
If I just change the replicas to five,
is that okay?
Sure. Yeah.
What else can I break? Let's see.
So there's two sets of replicas then. We
have
Yes. Can you scroll up a little, and
let's see what that first replicas is? This
where you are right now, I know what
it is. It's the MySQL
level replicas.
But higher up, that's the number of Vitigates.
So gateway is Vitigate.
So replicas
five will give you five Vitigate pods.
Okay.
So that's not replicas of my data. That's
just like okay. We don't actually need five
of them then. That's not the interest in
one.
So I guess we wanna modify the key
space here,
and we'd wanna modify the replicas of the
key space to be
does the does the number matter? Do I
have to have a certain quorum? Does it
have to be odd or does does it
not No. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
What about two, but at least two, but
beyond that, it doesn't matter.
Okay.
So one of the things I'd like to
do then is why don't we scale this
up to four?
Is there a way for us, like, will
one of them be considered the leader then,
the primary?
So there is already a primary.
The operator should just add two more and
make them point to the existing primary
and not switch to a new primary.
Then can I kill the primary and things
will just
handle nicely? Yes. You you yeah. You can
kill the primary, and one of the others
should become a primary.
Let's see.
Alright. Yeah. Let's just see. Let's see.
What's the worst that could happen?
Actually, well, I I know what will happen,
but we'll see it happen, and then we'll
talk about it. Okay.
So we can see that your tab the
Vitess tablets are now spinning up, they're going
through the edit container phase, probably already finished.
Too many clicks.
Oh, we got one error. I wonder if
that's just transient.
Yeah, there we go. Okay.
Although we did get two restarts on these
ones. Wonder if that's going up.
No. Okay. It seems to have stabilized.
So now we have four replicas.
How would I work out which one is
the leader? Would that be come back to
the UI or is there another way of
handling that? You can do command line utility
with the port forward if you had the
alias.
You can connect you
can connect to VT gates and
say show Vitess tablets and it'll give you
which ones are what they are doing. Okay.
Now do I do that with standard MySQL
CLI? Or Yeah. MySQL CLI and but you
need to do a port forward and
I don't think I have it, but we
can get it.
It's in the The other
yeah. The other way to do it is
to connect to the VTCTLD
that
well, we only forwarded the HTTP port. But
if we forwarded the gRPC port, then we
would be able to do list all tablets,
and we'll get a list of all the
tablets. A couple of options.
But, you know, for
if you already are, like, MySQL user
CLI,
for me, like, remembering the flags are are
harder because it's new terms. Right? But
just
connect to
database and say say show databases and stuff
like that so maybe you can explore a
little bit.
Yeah. Of course.
I'm confused. VT gate. Did we not have
two VT gates out there?
No. No. We just had one.
That was in the service. When we looked
at the service, there were two services which
Okay. Yeah. Right.
Do you know the port number that I
wanna port forward?
Yeah. It's
15306.
15 3 0 6.
15 3 0 6. Okay.
We have our port forward running. We have
access to my
I
just installed you.
You need to set an alias
to your Well, let's let's
Let's go to client. Oh, okay. You need
a client. Right? I'll just
export this. I think it just got a
little confused.
Yeah. There we go. Okay. So now we
have a a client.
Can I just do my SQL
local host
dash p? Local host
15 o three. Yes.
Minus u user. Yeah.
Oh, I think it's capital h, isn't it?
No.
I think it's capital p.
Capital p p.
For the host? P is like looking for
a password. For the port number.
Port number. Capital p. Yeah.
Yeah. That's correct.
Yeah. It's not trying to use the host.
I'm wondering if that h is correct. Oh,
let's try +1 27001
instead of local host.
Yeah.
Oh, that was closer.
Last connection.
It might put forward.
Oh, we got refused
there. I'm gonna describe that pods just in
case.
Scrape pod. And it was the gate. Right?
Yeah.
And the ports
oh, three three zero six then. 3 3
0 6. Yes. You need to do I
was looking at that +1 5306
to 3306.
So is this you know, you should be
glad when it's always those little silly errors.
Those are the ones I don't mind. Yeah.
Now you want
now you can take out the port
specification
because
it's the default port.
I'm in.
There you go.
Show Vitess underscore tablets.
Underscore.
Okay. Yeah. Alright. So we can see we've
got our zone one. We have our commerce
database.
This is uncharted.
We've got three replicas and one primary.
Awesome, very, very cool.
Now I'm assuming
these aliases
maybe match up with those IDs on the
Let's check. Yeah, I don't like getting this
many splits, but I'll do
Yeah. Three three. Yeah. Okay. So these are
pod names. So those are still a random
thing on the end, but Right. We want
to kill two four six.
So Right. The rep.
Delete pod.
So
what should happen here when I do this?
There was not gonna an application that's consistently
hitting it. So I'm doing it. We're probably
not gonna be able to like visually see
fail over, but I'm assuming when I delete
this pod,
if I run our show tablets again,
have will we see some sort of status
or degradation here or will it just immediately
switch to offline,
and will something else take over? Like
Well, we
will see that that
so that tablet may not even show up
and show Vitess tablets depending on when we
run it, depending on what state it is
in at that point.
And
what the operator does, and this is different
from how, most people run Vitess in their
live installs,
is that
it's actually so quick to restart the tablet
and reattach it to its volume and reconnect
it to the MySQL that it doesn't do
a failover.
It just restarts it. So
so the pod will simply restart. So we'll
see whether I'm right about that.
Guess we'll just wait for this to
to at least finish Cause I guess until
cube control tells me the pause delete, it's
probably not actually gone yet.
I wonder if we've already got a new
one spinning up.
I've got too many tabs.
We just use a new window. Yeah. There
we go. So we got
one initializing.
We got three replicas now. So we've lost
our leader. We've lost the master. Yeah.
The primary.
So when that new pod comes online,
will it just take over?
It will come back as primary. Okay.
And what if it's away for
an hour?
You know? An hour? Uh-huh. Yeah. What what
if I what if it goes away for
three days? What if I run it on
bare metal and the hard drive dies and
I shut down the machine there?
So what we haven't shown
in this example
is that you can integrate Vitess Orchestrator,
which will actually
do a failover.
Don't know if that's stuck.
It looks okay here.
Well, it just take a a bit of
time before it shows up on the oh,
no. There we go. Back. Yeah.
And so what happens with write requests that
come in during that time when there's there's
no leader available?
So Vitigate,
I'm not sure if we have set this
up in this example, but Vitigate can buffer
the request.
And let's say,
on the client side, you have some sort
of a time out, fifteen seconds as you
right?
Vitigate will buffer the request for a specified
duration.
By default, it's, like, twenty seconds, but you
can set it up to thirty seconds.
And,
Vitigate will buffer the request. If the client
times out, the client can retry.
If the client doesn't time out, once the
primary is back up, Vitigate will,
send the request again,
and they will succeed.
Okay. There will just be a delay.
Something that you expect to take one second
might come back after twenty seconds or twenty
five seconds.
Okay.
Is there anything else that's interesting
to the way that the test had?
I think Google was thinking I was talking
to it. Is there anything
interesting
that we could show from, you know, now
that we're in this kind of MySQL prompt
thing,
is there any other Vitess
specialized objects that we can show, describe the
schemas, and for that that would be useful
to the people viewing at home?
I think we can also do show with
the key spaces.
And is would that be describable?
I can't even remember if this is real
MySQL syntax. I'm kind of just making that
up. No. No. It's
oh, nope.
Not yet.
No. You can say
use commerce
and and say show show tables.
Yeah. In fact, you can do show tables
even without
Yeah. Doing use commerce. Yeah.
One of the But we didn't actually select
the default database. That's why when we connected,
it didn't actually have yeah.
So
these are the these are the tables that
initial setup created in the commerce database.
Right. WordPress itself Yeah. That's WordPress metadata.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So one of the things Vitess
can do is you can actually have multiple
key spaces and have a VT gate that
spans those
and
have
the illusion
of a single database as long as the
table names don't overlap.
So sometimes what people will do
is instead of sharding
let's say instead of having many large tables
or a few large tables, they have many,
many, many small tables, and the overall database
size is big. Then you can split those
into
multiple MySQL databases,
give each of them a different name,
and at the Vitess level, you'll get the
illusion that they're all still in a single
database
as long as the table names don't collide.
Ah, okay.
That's actually super cool. I mean,
there are, like, few blog posts about about
this, like,
million tables in one database. Like, million database.
The million tables. Like, the the customer create
a
table per customer. So every customer gets one
table. Table per user. Table per user.
Table I've I've seen that also. Table for
user is also another practice that just to
skip try to scale out. You know? I
think But, eventually, they they have a problem
managing that many objects.
I think that's a really interesting use case.
You know, I I'm I'm in Europe where
GDPR is a really big thing, and companies
are looking for ways to segment and isolate
certain countries data or certain, you know, studies
data or even not, you know, maybe per
user to a certain degree, they really wanna
just be able to make it easy to
wipe that away after the GDPR timeframes, etcetera.
So I could see a lot of really
interesting use cases for adopting that
VT gate across multiple case based thing. That
would be very interesting to me definitely. That's
even lower level than the zone and the
cells. So you actually have the zone.
Let's just
in GDPR case, you can actually zone out
all the countries. Right? And then you can
actually set set them on a cell per
data center, like, availability zone,
and then drill down even further
by region, by, you know,
state, county, or or that. And then you
can all do that within this
design. So the extremely
interesting
use case.
Yeah. So I just wanna make sure I
understood that correctly. Like, I'm designing an application
where users can register
and I want to store all of the,
you know, all of the people that are
in The US and a US zone, I
wanna store all the European people, maybe I'm
like London zone
and then I wanna use
I wanna be able to break them down
by user type and say I break them
down into a key space each. So you're
saying that t I could run a v
t k in each geographic location which would
handle the request for that specific
continent?
Yep. Yes. Okay.
Cool. So Slack actually does this. They have
the data locality. When you create a Slack
work you can choose which region you want
your data to reside in,
and they use Vitess, and they are doing
it. And are these VT gates aware of
one another if I make a request from
a let's say I'm traveling, right, and all
my data is hosted in the Scottish data
center, assuming we have any. And I'm in,
you know, Amsterdam or California for a business
trip, and I log in to the VT
gate there, does that know to move me
over there, or would it fail?
Like, what would happen?
That's a good question.
You can set up the VT gates to
be able to access data in other
zones, but there'll be a latency.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's
I I don't know how long this will
take, but I'll suggest you on one more
thing. If we think it's gonna take too
long, let's just not do it. We can
go back to the documentation and maybe actually
stick to the what we were gonna do
for a while. But
when we created this key space, it was
uncharted.
Right? So if I run that command again,
the show key spaces. No.
Show tablets.
Yeah.
This dash here means uncharted. Is that right?
Right.
Can we chart this?
Yes. It's documented.
We can look at the documentation to see
how we should do it.
Okay.
That's fine.
Let's see.
Can I just search?
We should go go back we should go
back to that guide that we were in,
and there's a link from there to go
to
the next steps. So get started
with this operator. Next
steps.
So is there move tables?
Let's click on move tables. We don't need
to do move tables because
we are not trying to split
the existing key space into multiple key spaces.
We just want to shard.
So we can go all the way to
the end and
resharding. Yeah. That's what we want to do.
So my resharding ideas in the advanced track.
Okay.
So
So the the
the part that takes time is to define
those indexes
all of the tables. And with WordPress, there
are quite a few tables.
So for each of those tables, you'll you
ideally need to inspect the schema, pick a
column, pick a index type. Hash is the
most common,
but there are multiple index types.
So it's probably be very beneficial if I
even knew what the WordPress schema looked like.
It's kinda Yeah. So in in WordPress example,
I looked,
earlier
was
you have a blog site. Right? So
you would keep one uncharted
key space for your metadata.
But for the blog,
you would actually have a charted key space
by the, you know, blog ID or or
or comments,
users that we would need to scale. You
don't need to scale your
metadata because it only, like, keeps track of
users, how many they they like, how many
they commented, and stuff like that. But but
you need what you need to scale in
that example
is the number of comments from the users.
Right? You actually have to split them up
so that they don't actually stack into one
area.
So that's that's why
there is some assembly required before
you decide a shard on what type of
sharding you want to do on those. And
and and and Deepthi's comment on hash is
very common because
that way you can say, okay. I want
n number of shards and shard
them by hash, which is
kind of easy way of doing it.
And it usually gives you a pretty good
distribution if you're hashing a numeric field
because that's important when you're sharding. You don't
want some shards to be
overloaded and some shards to be very sparse.
But I can make a great point. I
skipped over the move tables thinking that, okay.
If you want to reshard, then you'll reshard
all tables. But no no. Not necessarily.
Some tables are always gonna be small, so
you will move them out into a key
space that you don't intend to shard, and
then you'll take your main key space and
shard that.
Okay. That makes sense.
Well, I'm not confident in my ability to
work through the WordPress schema and and try
try and identify how we should share that.
So if we were to take a look
at one more thing, is there anything that
either of you would like me to click
on here and lead me towards?
I don't I think the the one thing
the one thing I want to talk about
is hortro protection.
Okay. That's good. Vitess
Vitess does query consolidation.
So let's say that many clients are looking
for the same thing. I don't know. Top,
top voted comment or something. Everybody wants to
click on the top post. Right?
Vitess can detect
that there are many queries which are identical,
including the bind variables.
And there's no need to send each and
every one of those queries to the underlying
MySQL.
If one of those queries is in flight,
then you can hold everything else, wait for
the result from the first query, and send
that same result back to your thousand or
10,000 callers.
So these are, some of this is one
of those features that makes Vitess useful regardless
of sharding. Even if you are never gonna
shard, you're still going to get some protections
from thundering herds and those kinds of problems.
Yeah. I think
what what I've seen in the past when
people are trying to do something similar to
this is that they're usually bringing on another
database tool like Redis, and they're trying to,
like, analyze the query and remove any of
the variants and then cache them in there,
and it's very complicated. But is that something
that by adopting the test I get? Is
it something I have to enable? Do I
have to tweak it? Like,
is that running already in our setup just
now?
Query consolidation is on by default. You would
have to turn it off if you didn't
want it for some reason.
Okay.
What I would like to highlight
is
we talked about backup recovery. It actually did
like, in order to if you were, like,
old school DBA, in order to build a
replica,
if your node died as a DBA, you
would actually had very hard time trying to
figure out the coordinates of your replica, your
backup. You would actually have to restore it
and find it, set those,
you know, change master to commands and and
all that stuff. Right? You know, need to
pinpoint. And if you actually made a mistake,
you know, fat fingered it, you would actually
maybe screw up the entire cluster, roll forward
to wrong position, things like that. The other
thing that
is in Vitess right now,
we are very proud of is the integration
to online DDL, which is also another operational
not headache. Nightmares. Nightmares.
As
an operational DBA myself for the last last
last, you know, 25,
it's it's it's a pain. Right? And you
do just just all you want to make
a a a schema change, which is very
common. And and with with online DDL options,
you actually can utilize one of those, utilities
that are very common without
having to lock
and and impose a metadata lock and and
actually stop the application doing that. So
you can actually test it out. It's built
in right now. It's experimental,
and and we are actually enhancing it as
the maintainers. When we say we are, we
there's a large group of engineers working on
it. And,
and and you can set the DDL strategy
to,
ghost or or p t o s c,
and then do alter table, one of those
tables, and see how that goes.
And that would not actually,
you know,
cause,
any lock on the database while the WordPress
application is running, and it would actually apply
those changes and it will be managed. And
you'll know the progress of it and things
like that. So it's a it's a new
development in Vitess world.
Nice. Lots of really interesting and cool features
there. And there was something that popped in
my head just as you you both were
kind of chatting away there. And,
like, if
I were just running MySQL or MariaDB,
like it's, you know, I fat fingered enough
databases in my career. And I made up
I've deleted a lot of tables by mistake
or even filled databases like,
and, you know, you come to rely on
like the binary log and point in time
backups. Is that something that I still have
access to when I go through the test?
You absolutely have. You can connect to the
back end databases. You can mark around, download
the bin logs,
look look troubleshoot,
and and audit your database. The the database,
like like I said, database remains as database.
It's the back end database. Still the good
old MySQL.
You can access the ports and and all
the binaries
and the and the logs,
and the binary logs
is is still there. We just
don't
do that anymore. We let let the Vitess
handle all that stuff.
Alright. Well Vitess itself
sorry.
Just one more thing. We actually have a
point in time recovery feature as well,
which is documented on the website.
And it's
okay. Let's pull up the website again. Let's
take a look at that. So
It's probably an advanced feature somewhere.
Oh, we should just search for it. Yeah.
Maybe.
I wonder if I can just yeah. Point
and time recover.
I like it as well. It's even the
docs have a decent search functionality and I
don't have to look too hard.
So it's just taking advantage of the fact
that, you know, all of the requests are
going through the VT gates and and then
you're you're doing, like, a multi rate to
some metadata store to understand what happened on
each
individual DB?
It it relies on the bin logs. Alright.
Okay. So it does require a bin log
server
so that we can replay the bin logs.
So it so we we have periodic backups,
so we will find the backup that is
closest to the desired time and then replay
the bin logs starting from that position until
you get to the time you want it.
Is it a bad thing? Like, you know,
if I'm running the tests and I
skip over it and go directly to my
MySQL DB or my MariaDB, does that cause
problems? Like, should everything go through Vitess? Or
Queries don't have to go through Vitess. You
can write
update data on the back end. That'll be
fine.
But
configuration
changes may conflict with how Vitess wants to
run things. So it's not gonna be a
good idea to do config changes on the
back end. Yeah. That makes sense. You know,
I think I'm already sold anyway. Like, I
think
the I think the amount of features and
and, you know, operational help that Vitess is
bringing to people that are working with these
two databases, like, it just seems like a
no brainer. Like, you probably do want to
adopt this technology and and use it. And
you've already mentioned a few very large company
names, YouTube and
there was one other just a few moments
ago, the fact that they're using Slack. Slack.
Exactly. Right. You know, they're using less technology
as well. I think that should give people
a lot of confidence and hopefully gives them
that little peak of interest to go and
and check it out for themselves.
Is there anything else either of you would
like to finish with before I let you
go and enjoy the rest of your day?
Just
just quick quick note on on the
Vitess project. We have a a Slack channel,
Vitess. If there are questions on on Vitess,
that is the most active place to ask
about Vitess.
Even if it's a newbie question, that's like
a general channel is is great for that.
The code is open source. GitHub is is
a great resource for for
research and development.
And and as you already gone through the
docs, you we already have it. And and
and if there are any questions
to either of us or the rest of
the maintainers, again, with the Slack channel or
or
Twitter is is a good communication channel.
Alright. Perfect. We are both on Twitter, and
there's a Vitess.io
Twitter
account as well.
Yeah. Well, all of the Twitter links are
in the show notes. I will make sure
that I drop a link to your Slack
channel in there as well. So people feel
free to jump into the description, join,
and have
fun with the test. And I'm sure that
you'd both be happy to help if anyone
does have any challenges or problems. Alright.
Well, I'll let you both go, please. Thank
you for joining me today. Have a great
Thank you very much. Meet you both soon.
Mhmm. Thank you for having us, David. Thank
you. Bye. Yep. Thank you.